nicolas vidal bonjour bonjour à vous
deux heureux de vous retrouver ce matin
en plateau sur rt france ce jean castex
et olivier ont donc tenu une conférence
de presse lundi après un nouveau conseil
de défense ce matin c'est ce qui vous
fait réagir oh oui ça y est je vais vous
le dire ce matin personnellement moi je
suis ragaillardi chu regonflé à bloc je
suis même refait un comme disent les
jeunes après ce 412e conseil défend dans
le bunker des manuels premier et puis
vous avez ce duo ce champion entre gens
de l'upra nos lives et la science côte à
côte dans la tempête soudés comme deux
élastiques dans cette conférence de
passe qui fera date mais chers amis oui
elle fera date cette conférence de
presse dans cette vème république car
cette fois ci c'était sublime s'est et
artistique c'était au niveau d'une fiat
pandemic et il ne manquait plus que la
peau de l'autre sous les pupitres et un
lustre fluo je suis sûr vous avez
apprécié comme moi ce ballet gracieux dû
jouer mon match je rêvais hommage mais
mon matin alors que les journalistes
étaient à remettre mais janot depuis ces
dernières bamboche et son tempo c est
positif puisque lupus a appris à garder
gracieusement ses distances et puis vous
aviez un souffle incroyable cette
conférence une fraîcheur stupéfiante et
une ardeur transportée loin de votre
train train quotidien
franchement entre nous ça avait de la
gueule et moi ils m'ont littéralement
porté arrivée déclarations comme la
situation n'est pas et il a mené pas la
même que l'année dernière grâce à la
vaccination nous a dit jean castex en
même temps la cinquième vague est plus
fort que la troisième nous assure
olivier ferrand ou encore la semaine
d'avant de celle d'après c'était moins
compliqué ayant enfin en comparaison du
benchmark et autres pays hélas là les
amis vous vous rendez compte que vous
êtes en présence d'une intelligence
supérieure contre laquelle vous ne
pouvez pas lutter alors vous devez
accepter la supériorité de l'être aimé
et c'est bien comme ça elle va néanmoins
elle n'y connaît les discothèques sont
donc les grandes perdantes elles vont
devoir fermer un mois comment est ce
qu'on peut comprendre cette décision
selon vos bien j'ai envie de vous dire
que face à de tel génie en est
finalement que bien peu de chose alors
on s'écrase on ne peut qu'accepter
souscrire suivre aveuglément de telles
mesures prises avec autant de
discernement et d'intelligence alors oui
peut-être peut-être qu'on peut se
hasarder ce matin ont formulé quelques
modestes conseils à nos dieux de
l'olympe sanitaires pour donner de
l'espoir aux propriétaires de
discothèques alors alors on dit pourquoi
ne pas organiser dans de nuit au lieu de
les fermer des soirées à thème sous les
tous les week-end autour de la
vaccination avec dj freezer aux platines
où tout le monde serait déguisé alors
leurs seins seringue l'autre en flacons
de gel hydroalcoolique un autre masque
ffp2 celui-là on qr code et un autre
dans une évocation de gestes barrières
ça changerait de bob l'eponge de winnie
l'ourson et de spiderman et on pourrait
aussi proposer trois footer gratuit un
accès au vestiaire à chaque dose à
chaque doigt et surtout pour la
troisième dose idem pour la quatrième à
venir bien entendu ça serait pédagogique
et ludique pour que notre jeunesse
poursuit son schéma vaccinal sous les
rythmes endiablées des tubes des années
80 en somme en somme une injection sur
un air de gilbert montagné et au lit les
copains ou alors il faut faire plus
simple est délocalisée dans les salons
de mystère des outre-mer ou ceux du
ministère de l'intérieur qui se sont
tenues très récemment de grosses grosses
bamboche mais pour ça mais pour ça il
faut voir avec le est débarquée du
gouvernement en la personne de jean
castex et pour revenir à cette
conférence de presse les laurel et hardy
gouvernement ont fait d'autres annonces
du dos voilà qui mérite qu'on s'y arrête
effectivement il était question des
interactions sociales des pots de départ
et surtout de la vaccination des enfants
et qu'est ce qu'on doit en retenir
nicholas abbey un mot n'a pas un mot
n'est pas que les 10 et s emballer un
art est maintenant au petit déjeuner ça
sort un bol de chocapic un coude
seringue pour nos chères petites têtes
blondes dès janvier prochain et
d'ailleurs on a une petite pensée émue
pour nos enfants chanceux qui ont
retrouvé la joie irrespirable de porter
à nouveau masque pour aller faire du
sport jouer dans la cour et interagir
avec leurs camarades et en même temps il
n'est jamais trop tôt les amis pour
inculquer la philosophie du bâillon et
du tu te tais m'affronte arles du côté
des interactions sociales avec jean de
doliprane nous a demandé de lever le
pied droit levé 1 mais bon le problème
c'est comme les recettes de cuisine si
on ne connaît pas le dosage et demie la
quantité c'est un peu compliqué il y
aurait eu plus au moins de donner une
posologie comme par exemple ben vous
voyez pas plus de deux apéros par
semaine papy et mamie c'est une fois par
semaine les parents c'est trois fois par
semaine par contre le chien et le chat
c'est aucune restriction bon ta taille
tant de temps c'est pas la peine car on
s'est fâché avec eux afin du vaccin a
donc avancé mme à la peine et tu cher
ami de la goutte au nez pour vos pots de
départ c'est râpé cette année comme
disait ma grand mère cette année il va
être ne pourra pas fêter son pot de
départ la retraite car jean doliprane 2
on du sérail de louche en chef l'a
décidé alors ne désespérez pas il nous
reste encore les enterrements mais
jusqu'à quand et puis pour nos amis
skieurs va falloir à bord et votre pas
sanitaires pour s'accrocher au tire
fesses sinon préférer les télécabines
card plus vous montez - vous risquez
sachez aussi que les canons à neige
seront masqués à cet hiver il faut le
dire pour éviter que le au micro on
s'accroche à vogondy en tout cas qu'on
voit ce qu'on voit qu'on entend ce qu'on
entend on a bien raison de constance et
à andré henry de montherlant ne le
contredira pas lorsqu'il écrivait je
cite quand la bêtise gouverne
l'intelligence et hommes d'eli alors en
route pour une quatrième dose de
prestige
des masques avec des moufles à anvers a
battu comme un diable est pour la
raquette et la fondue
merci en extérieur et en intérieur
merci beaucoup nicolas c'était l'édito
politique de nicolas vidal ce matin